the Assassin's Creed movie takes place  in both modern-day and 15th century  Spain and the dialogue will match I'm  Tony and this is your GameSpot news  update an espanol  it was previously announced that the  movie is 65% modern day 35% in the past  director Justin Cruz el has now  confirmed that the historical scenes  will be in Spanish adding quote  exoticness and richness to the film  presumably there will be subtitles for  those of us who aren't fluent in Spanish  and if it adds as much as the director  claims you won't even mind a bit of  reading assassin's creed opens on  December 21st the movies cast includes  Michael Fassbender Marion Cotillard  Jeremy Irons and more you can read up on  plenty more about the movie over at  GameSpot and to hear our thoughts when  the film premieres you're already in the  right place